rumored x's olivia rodrigo and joshua
bassett seem to be on good terms
jj candles i'm sorry i'm just reading
all your comments i love you guys so
much uh yes people are just loving this
olivia and josh attended the season
three premiere of high school musical
the musical the series and they even
posed together on the red carpet i mean
look at that oh my gosh
good for them like what i did there so
of course fans have had long suspect
suspicions that josh is the subject of
the biggest song of last year olivia's
massive hit driver's license in addition
to a number of other songs off her debut
album sour and back in december josh
revealed to gq that he and olivia had
not spoken since the release of driver's
license it's really nice to see that
they are reunited and seem to be on good
terms that's right here's more from the
red carpet with josh and original high
school musical star corbin blue take
care everyone thanks for joining us see
you next time bye bye
the high school musical the musical the
series season three premiere it's a
beautiful night in hollywood it's so
fantastic i mean to have been here in
season one so long ago like it's crazy
to be finally back here now that we can
you know and it's just awesome to see
people and see their faces and it's a
really special night this cast is so
insanely talented and they've welcomed
me as one of their own peers actually
witnessing this new generation
experiencing that same joy
that i know that infused our lives over
15 years ago and then getting a chance
to come back and experience it all over
again and in such a new light in a fresh
take and in a way that i get to make fun
of myself i get to have fun with it like
it's
it couldn't be better